und sie sehen wir schon die abgeordneten
wechselnden bekommen zu einem ganz
anderen aspekt der politik zur
außenpolitik die fdp fraktion hat einen
antrag eingereicht in dem sie eine
nationale sicherheitspolitische
gesamtstrategie fordert denn ihrer
meinung nach gibt es zu wenig real
politischen gestaltungswillen um auf die
aktuellen herausforderungen einer
veränderten weltordnung zu reagieren und
deswegen hofft sie mit diesem antrag
dass es von der bundesregierung eine
strategie gibt in der man eine
langfristige
realistische und stringente strategie
formuliert
und des außenministerin annalena
baerbock die wir auch eben im statement
gesehen haben hat auch eine nationale
sicherheitsstrategie für ende des jahres
versprochen unter anderem nachdem es
eben mit dem russischen angriffskrieg
eine veränderte
sicherheitspolitische lage gibt
für diese debatte jetzt aber wird als
erstes auch von der afg auch ein wunder
sprechen mitglied im auswärtigen
ausschuss und stellvertretender sprecher
für aussenpolitik seiner fraktion
der präsident wer die kollegen nach
diesem emotionalen thema ein nüchternes
politisches thema seit jahren ein seit
jahrzehnten wird in deutschland in
fachkreisen über das thema der fehlenden
nationalen sicherheitspolitischen
gesamtstrategie diskutiert das thema
erreicht in krisenzeiten für kurze zeit
auch die aufmerksamkeit der politischen
parteien und der medien und verschwand
dann regelmäßig wieder aus der
diskussion
strategische realität war bis heute dass
deutschland seine energiepolitik nach
moskau seine wirtschaftspolitik nach
bissingen und seine sicherheitspolitik
nach washington outgesourced hat und der
rest wird zumeist in brüssel entschieden
der deutschen sicherheitspolitik mangelt
es also bereits seit langen an
langfristigen nationalen strategischen
zielsetzungen um dem versprechen des
grundgesetzes an den deutschen bürger
nach frieden freiheit sicherheit und
wohlstand gerecht zu werden
den aktuellen herausforderungen einer
sich dramatisch verändernden welt
ordnung und einem immer härter werdenden
internationalen system wettbewerb ist
deutschland daher zunehmend nicht
gewachsen die ursache hierfür ist auch
das fehlen einer langfristigen
realistischen stringenten und
ideologiefreien nationalen strategie die
deutsche interessen klar und deutlich
formuliert
daher ist es grundsätzlich zu begrüßen
dass sich die bundesregierung
vorgenommen hat im ersten jahr ihrer
amtszeit eine nationale
sicherheitsstrategie vorzulegen jedoch
greift der ansatz den die
außenministerin bei der
auftaktveranstaltung zur entwicklung
einer solchen nationalen
sicherheitsstrategie vorlegte deutlich
zu kurz
eine nationale sicherheitsstrategie zu
erarbeiten diese fortlaufend kritisch in
der gesamten bandbreite
zu evaluieren und fortzuschreiben und
vor allen dingen deren umsetzung zu
überwachen und durchzusetzen kann nicht
die verantwortung eines einzelnen
ressorts seien das muss unbedingt
chefsache werden
die offensichtliche schwachstellen des
krisenmanagements im zusammenhang mit
dem ukraine krieg unterstreichen dies
nachdrücklich
innen und außenpolitische sicherheits
entwicklungen lassen sie schon lange
nicht mehr getrennt betrachten heutige
und künftige komplexe herausforderungen
können nur bewältigt werden wenn außen-
verteidigungs- innen- wirtschafts- und
energiepolitische dimensionen mit
einbezogen und im wohlverstandenen
nationalen interesse angegangen werden
denn tragfähige realpolitische lösungen
und strategische sicherheitspolitische
entscheidungen bedürfen eines weiten
blick nach vorn sowie klar definierter
nationaler sicherheitspolitischer ziele
liegt eine solche realpolitische
durchdringung der welt sicherheitslage
nicht vor kann die bundesregierung
bestenfalls kurzfristig auf kritische
ereignisse
reagieren wir kennen dieses fahren auf
sicht aus den letzten jahren zu genüge
mittel und langfristig führt diese
politik jedoch zu weiteren verlust an
handlungsspielraum in der außen-
sicherheits- und wirtschaftspolitik und
damit zu einer steigenden abhängigkeit
von anderen mächten wir erleben es
gerade insbesondere in der gescheiterten
energiepolitik im zusammenhang mit den
mit dem trick in der ukraine und seinen
folgen äußerst schmerzhaft
deutschland muss also in die lage
versetzt werden den drohenden abstieg im
internationalen konzert zu verhindern
und seine nationalen interessen die dem
wohl der bürger zu dienen haben auch
durchsetzen zu können vor diesem
hintergrund beantragen wir
umgehend den derzeitigen
bundessicherheitsrat zu einem ständigen
ressort übergreifenden nationalen
sicherheitsrat umzubauen und mit
effizienten und schlanken strukturen
nicht unbedingt nach amerikanischen er
nach französischen und japanischen aber
auch österreichischen vorbild auszubauen
diese dieser nationale sicherheitsrat
setzt sich zusammen aus dem für einen
bereiten sicherheitsbegriff relevanten
ministern und wird vom bundeskanzler
geführt ein nationaler
sicherheitsberater
der direkt dem bundeskanzler untersteht
und dessen stab im kanzleramt
angesiedelt ist führt die täglichen
geschäfte dieses nationalen
sicherheitsrates er hat dazu auch zugang
zu den relevanten informationen
insbesondere den jeweiligen lagezentren
aller betroffenen ressorts mit diesem
instrumentarium sollte die
bundesregierung in die lage versetzt
werden präventiv und langfristige
strategien zu entwickeln in einer
deutschen nationalen gesamte
sicherheitsstrategie zu
institutionalisieren und dann auch
umzusetzen
um diese deutliche stärkung der position
des bundeskanzlers in der exekutive
demokratisch zu legitimieren soll dazu
ein geeignetes parlamentarisches
kontrollgremium eingerichtet werden
werte kollegen vor dem hintergrund der
zunehmenden unsicherheiten und risiken
in der welt bitte ich sie
parteipolitische überlegungen hinten
anzustellen und unserem antrag
zuzustimmen vielen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
vielen dank herr kollege
liebe kolleginnen kollegen sie erleben
jetzt eine historische moment ich
erteile den kollegen dr stegner spd
fraktion das wort
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident
jugendliches alter produziert sehr viel
altersweisheit das muss ich hin zur
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ausgerechnet jetzt während putins
brutaler angriffskrieg mitteleuropa
wütet und sich eine große
staatengemeinschaft in die seite der
ukraine stellt ausgerechnet jetzt kommt
die afg mit an der
sicherheitspolitischen gesamtstrategie
daher sicher ist da nur sie haben nichts
aber auch gar nichts aus der geschichte
des 20 jahrhunderts gelernt ihr deutsche
nationale antrag besteht aus anti
multilateralismus der üblichen hetze
gegen eine humanitäre flüchtlingspolitik
und daran zicken deutschtümelei ihr
unseligen vorgängerparteien von freunden
autoritärer regime feinden unserer
pressefreiheit die breit wenig
propaganda lügen und
verschwörungstheorien verbreiten
brauchen wir nun wirklich keine
empfehlung für unsere politik meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren und ihrem
antrag fehlt auch deswegen jede
seriosität weil sie zu putins
angriffskriegen die ukraine als einzige
fraktion in diesem hause keine klare
position haben ausgerechnet sie fordern
in ihrem andere an ideologiefreie außen
und sicherheitspolitik das ist doch
blanker hohn meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren ist jetzt schon tief blicken
das dass putin geschrieben immer wieder
die rechtsextremisten in den westlichen
demokratien politischen finanziell als
brüder im geiste unterstützt russische
kredite für marine panzers vom national
die gott sei dank trotzdem verloren hat
gegen emanuele makro einfluss kampagnen
aus moskau berlin os x 20 16 zugunsten
des rechtspopulisten und capitol
stürmers donald trump ihre leute fahren
so fragwürdigen konferenzen auf die krim
und ihre rechtsradikale partei
jugendwehr mit rubel bezahlt genau
dieser schulterschluss der rechten mit
den diktatoren dieser welt ist ein
sicherheitsrisiko für unsere demokratie
wir wollen keine liberale demokratie
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
und jetzt kannst du olaf scholz hat in
seiner zeitenwende rede die
neuorientierung unserer
sicherheitspolitik angekündigt sie
müssen nicht lernen nur weil sie kann
ihnen halter haben der krieg mitten in
europa erschütternde kriegsverbrechen an
der ukrainischen zivilbevölkerung zu
leben
er ist kollegen brandner von
rechtsradikalen dass ich nie zwischen
fragen zu der überwunden geglaubte
imperialismus der grenzen verschieben
will all das zeigt der kanzler hat recht
als abrüstungspolitische sprecher meiner
fraktion fällt es mir nicht leicht dass
wir neben der politischen finanziellen
humanitären hilfe für die ukraine auch
waffen in ein kriegsgebiet liefern am
ende wird allerdings eine politische
lösung stehen müssen weil die endlos
spirale von immer mehr und immer
schwereren waffen keine lösung ist aber
auch die deutung des veritas ist richtig
weil damit eine angemessene ausrüstung
und des parlaments unser parlamentsarmee
bewirkt wird und es nicht um aufrüstung
gehen darf es ist richtig was wir hier
zur unterstützung der ukraine
beschlossen haben und ist es auch
richtig dass wir das gemeinsam mit der
größten oppositionsfraktion gemacht
haben gerade deshalb allerdings sollten
sie von der union aufhören die friedens-
und ostpolitik von willy brandt walter
schilt leeger und bauen helmut schmidt
zu diskreditieren sie trug nämlich dazu
bei den kalten krieg zu beenden und für
große teile europas demokratie
zurückzugewinnen dass die folgen der
deutschen katastrophen des 20
jahrhunderts überwunden worden ist lag
an diesen weichenstellungen dem einsatz
mutiger bürgerrechtlern der
untergehenden ddr und der politischen
führung von george bush senior ob es
michael gorbatschow das sollten wir
niemals vergessen bei allem was dann
irrtümer und fehler gegeben haben
und der herr oppositionsführer sollte
sich schon den versuch verkneifen bei
dem sondervermögen für die bundeswehr
aus parteitaktik frei gewählte
abgeordnete für und in ihrem rechten aus
artikel 38 des grundgesetzes zu
beschneiden herr merz hat natürlich auch
jedes recht zu reisen reisen soll ja
bilden das allerdings was gesagt was ihr
druck angeblich bewirkt haben soll das
kommt eher aus der abteilung einbildung
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
und diese pose unterstreicht warum das
gut so ist dass der bundeskanzler oder
scholz heißt und mehr als
oppositionsführer auch unsere
außenministerin annalena baerbock hat
gerade in kiew von insbesondere im ort
des schreckens sind butter gezeigt wie
unsere verantwortliche wert geleitete
und realistische außenpolitik aussieht
danke dafür
und trotz der schmährufe aus der
opposition und wenigen verzichtbaren
fußnoten aus anderer richtung ist doch
gerade die besonderheit von olaf scholz
die die menschenwürde bundeskanzler
erwarten wenn es um fragen von krieg und
frieden geht meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren wir haben ihnen gemeinsam in
der ampelkoalition und wir haben den
gemeinsam mit unseren verbündeten
insbesondere washington und paris wenn
man sich manche presseartikel und äußern
was der union anschaut könnte man meinen
dass 16 lang jahrelang unionsgeführte
verteidigungsministerium hätte unter dem
einfluss der jusos und nicht unter dem
einfluss von rüstungskonzernen und
überteuerte beraterfirmen gestanden es
fehlt nur noch dass die partei
historiker und bei ihnen dem archiv des
konrad adenauer hauses das
spd-parteibuch von angela merkel finden
ich wäre allerdings vor sich wenn sie
dem stern zur veröffentlichung an bieten
wollen meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren ich finde trotz wichtiger
landtagswahlen wäre es auch sinnvoll
sich zur gemeinsamen verantwortung zu
bekennen die wir gemeinsam hatten in
berlin und auch in schwerin das ist
nämlich hier manchmal wirklich so dass
auch einen bessermacher ziehen
besserwisser kommen und ich füge hinzu
wenn wir heute in der debatte haben wir
gut und böse moralischen unmoralisch
putin freunde oder kriegsfall so dient
das der politischen kultur nicht auch
nicht wenn journalisten und
wissenschaftler kombattanten werden in
den social media jürgen habermas hat
völlig recht schwarz weiß ist keine gute
basis um in unserer gesellschaft eine
neue sicherheitspolitische konzerts
debatte zu führen gar keine basis dafür
ist dieser gefährliche fdp-antrag den
wir selbstverständlich ablehnen wir
brauchen nicht mehr europa und nicht
weniger nationalismus brauchen wir
unnötig wie ein kropf meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren und
ist sehr schwer zu afg anträgen zu reden
weil der meisten ohren sind drin steht
bei gestatten sie mir eine letzte
bemerkung gestatten sie mir eine letzte
bemerkung die bürger um den bürger in
schleswig holstein haben am letzten
sonntag bei all dem was mir an dem
ergebnis weniger gefällt einen
beachtlichen beitrag zur sicherheit
geleistet unserer freiheitlich
demokratischen grundordnung
sie haben ihre kameraden von rechtsaußen
aus dem landtag entfernt meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren mögen nrw und
andere länder folgen und die
rechtsradikalen auch aus diesem haus der
demokratie endlich wieder verschwinden
dann wird deutschland sicher
vielen dank herr kollege dr stegner es
war historisch weil gebäude über zehn
jahre das vergnügen schließlich scheinen
landtag miteinander hatten deshalb war
das heute historisch herr kollege
brandner hat und meine kunst
intervention gebeten die ich zu lassen
also meine befürchtung dass der auftritt
ist entsteht eher hysterisch als
historisch wird hat sich ja dann ist
nicht bewahrheitet und der steht wohl
sagen bisher hat kann sich ihre fakten
freien hass und hetztiraden eigentlich
nur von twitter aber das was sie jetzt
hier abgeliefert haben hat das ganze
noch getoppt wie man so schön sagt kein
wort zu unserem ansatz nur blanke
polemik so können sie vielleicht in
ihrem spd der spd ortsgruppe miteinander
umgehen die leute bestimmt war aber
nicht im deutschen bundestag ich glaube
sie sind weder intellektuell noch
politisch bisherigen deutschen bundestag
angekommen aber das ist jetzt eine
lässliche sünde ich meine das habe ich
vorher auch schon gewusst ich wollte
mich beziehen auf eine äußerung wie
gesagt die gemacht haben die
wahrscheinlich jetzt gleich massiv mit
fakten unterlegt wird meine partei oder
meine fraktion würde mit rubel bezahlt
der stegner können sie die exakten
zahlungsflüsse von rubel an meine partei
kurz mal hier skizzierten dankeschön
sie sind nicht dran jetzt sondern der
kollege stehen die gelegenheit zu
antworten
herr präsident die zwischen intervention
hat ja sehr deutlich gemacht ist der
geist tatsächlich links steht das wusste
ich auch vorher schon aber das haben
sich ausdrücklich noch einmal bewiesen
will daran erinnern wenn sie sich
dagegen wehren dass gestern abend hier
in diesem hause ein vertreter ihrer
fraktion sich auf die sportpalastrede
von goebbels bezogen hat der kollege
weingarten hat zu recht dass in jeder
ein grund wo es hingehört und wo ihre
vorgänger sind und was in der tat so
wissen was ich ein problem auch für
unsere sicherheit finde ist dass es
russische quellen gibt die rechtsextreme
arbeit unterstützen zum beispiel die
arbeit ihrer parteijugend die zu recht
über vom verfassungsschutz überwacht
wird weil das nämlich rechtsradikales
was die leute dort tun und insofern kann
ich nur sagen wie das genau abgewickelt
werden habe ich ehrlicherweise nicht
gekümmert ist habe ich auch nicht der
punkt das ist glaube ich nicht der punkt
fakt ist herr kollege brandner für den
ausdruck sind ein lügner italien ein
ordnungsruf und
ansonsten ist der kollege steht mit der
antwort noch nicht ganz fertig fakt ist
dass jeder auftritt hier beweist dass
die demokratischen parteien aus ihrer
richtung keinerlei hinweise auf deutsche
sicherheit brauchen die ist so unnötig
wie ein kropf
so damit ist das jetzt auch geklärt aber
nicht gegeben damit kommen wir zum
nächsten redner in dieser debatte
roderich kiesewetter einer der
profiliertesten außenpolitiker der union
spricht jetzt als nächstes
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren ich appelliere an uns dass die
nächsten rednerinnen und redner sich des
themas widmen wir haben ganz viele
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer das der
falsche beifall von der falschen seite
wir sollten uns über die zukunft unseres
landes unterhalten den antrag um das
gleich vorneweg zu sagen des
antragstellers lehnen wir ab weil sie
schlichtweg multilateralismus ablehnen
die vernetzung unseres landes weltweit
die unbedingt notwendig ist als zu
kompliziert bezeichnet damit ist das für
uns kein beratungs gegenstand lieber
herr kollege stegner ich habe mir
erhofft dass sie die gelegenheit nutzen
und aus der sicht der sozialdemokratie
ein beitrag wie die sozialdemokratie die
nationale sicherheitsstrategie sieht
leistet und wenn sie schon helmut
schmidt und willy brandt ins feld führen
bei der entspannungs politik dann führe
ich ins feld dass unter diesen beiden
bundeskanzlern es nicht den zwei prozent
anteil gab sondern unter willy brandt
3,4 prozent und bei helmut schmidt 3,1
prozent des bruttoinlandsprodukts für
verteidigung nehmen sie sich das als
vorbild 2 prozent haben sie ja schon
nicht liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir als union sind der bundesregierung
sehr dankbar dass sie das thema
nationale sicherheitsstrategie auf die
tagesordnung setzt wir sind es deshalb
nicht nur weil es bei uns auch im
wahlprogramm stand sondern weil wir mit
blick auf unsere bevölkerung einer
alternden gesellschaft den
herausforderungen die wir haben vom
klimawandel von bürgern von katastrophen
von migration und von extremer
sicherheitsbedrohungen durch den
völkerrechtswidrigen krieg russlands
herausforderungen haben die wir nicht
mehr mit dem tagesgeschäft bewältigen
können und wenn wir dann die knappen
ressourcen die deutschland hat ohne maß
und ohne ziel einfach fallweise ausgeben
oder verwenden dann wäre das eine große
fehlinvestition wir erleben das ja
gerade auch in der debatte über die 100
milliarden und das zwei prozent ziel
aber nationale sicherheitsstrategie ist
mehr und ich erwarte von der
bundesregierung dass sie hier den
bundestag intensiv einbindet denn es ist
die bevölkerung die letztlich das
oberste ziel in der verantwortung des
staates hat nämlich die schutz der
schutz unserer bevölkerung vor äußerer
gefahr vor inneren gefahren vor
bedrohungen für pandemien und viele mehr
das ist der eigentliche starts zweck
warum sich völker staaten
rechtsstaatlichkeit demokratien
parlamente gegeben haben und wenn wir
nun in einer alternden gesellschaft sind
werden wir in einer ganz großen
ressourcen konkurrenz sein und dann wird
es um die frage gehen wo setzen wir die
knappen mittel deswegen brauchen wir
eine nationale sicherheitsstrategie die
prioritäten beschreibt und daraus auch
fähigkeiten ableitet was wollen wir in
welcher weise erreichen wir als union
sind bereit die regierung hier zu
unterstützen und ich bin froh dass es
ein prozess ist er breit die bevölkerung
die think tanks das parlament
institutionen ausländische partner
einbindet aber wir sollten wenigstens
vier punkte betrachten die hierzu die
unbedingt eingebaut werden müssen das
erste ist der schutz unserer bevölkerung
wenn wir sicherheit bereit definieren
hier geht es um soziale sicherheit um
äußere und innere sicherheit und
wirtschaftliche wettbewerbsfähigkeit
und das alles muss natürlich auf der
wirtschaftlichen wettbewerbsfähigkeit
aufbauen damit wir die gelder haben für
innere äußere und soziale sicherheit und
da stehen wir in einer internationalen
konkurrenz wo wir uns partner suchen
müssen und wertschöpfungsketten suchen
müssen die uns nicht erpressbar machen
ich blicke auf china zweitens brauchen
wir eine bundeswehr die das
außenpolitische handeln unseres landes
verlässlich als instrument von smart und
hard power unterstreicht und drittens
brauchen wir eine strategische kultur
die aus den abzuleitenden fähigkeiten
und den notwendigen priorisierungen das
ermöglicht was die außenministerin
diplomatie und härte bezeichnet wir
haben uns zu lange gleich unter welcher
regierung mit der
mit dem narrativ beschäftigt wir sind
von freunden und partnern umgeben und
mit dem archiv klang leider an herr
stegner wandel durch handel wandel durch
annäherung wandel durch verflechtung wer
sich in den letzten 20 30 jahren
geändert hat ist nicht russland sondern
das sind wir wir haben uns abhängig
gemacht durch billige energie aus
russland durch vergleichsweise günstigen
schutz aus den usa und durch billige
wertschöpfungsketten aus china so wird
es nicht weitergehen weil wir in einer
systemischen konkurrenz mit china und
russland sein werden und die
afrikanischen staaten sehr genau schauen
werden helfen wir der ukraine helfen wir
dass sie teil wird der rechtsstaatlichen
ordnung dass sie teil wird der
europäischen union einer friedensordnung
oder lassen sie wir sie durch zögern und
zaudern in ein chaos stürzen aus dem sie
nicht mehr herauskommt
warum sollen sich dann afrikanische
staaten an die seite der eu stellen und
unsere regelbasierte internationale
ordnung verteidigen wenn wir wenn es
darauf ankommt nicht in der lage sind
die werte mit ihnen gemeinsam zu
schützen und wenn es sein muss auch zu
verteidigen
deshalb lassen sie mich abschließend
sehr deutlich ein appell richten nutzen
wir die nächsten
redebeiträge aber auch die nächsten
debatten über die nationale
sicherheitsstrategie dafür dass wir eine
strategische kultur in deutschland
entwickeln beispielsweise eine woche der
sicherheit jedes jahr wie wir eine
haushaltswoche haben beispielsweise eine
evaluierung unseres außenpolitischen
handelns dass die bundesregierung
vorstellt aber eben auch dass wir einen
aufgewerteten bundessicherheitsrat haben
das entscheidungs vorbereitungs und
koordinierungsgremium der regierung
hilft interessen zur formulierung
position zu erarbeiten in eu nato osze
und vereinten nationen in diesem sinne
habe ich dafür dass wir eine breite
inklusive debatte haben wenn die
bundesregierung ist wünscht werden wir
als union das intensiv unterstützen
ansonsten machen wir eigene vorschläge
[Applaus]
und wir kommen jetzt so merle
spellerberg für die grünen unter anderen
opfer
unterausschusses abrüstung
rüstungskontrolle und nichtverbreitung
präsident liebe kolleginnen ich schließe
mich dem kollegen gerne in einer sache
an und rede zur sache
der brutale angriffskrieg
der brutale angriffskrieg auf die
ukraine ist nicht nur ein angriff auf
das leben und die freiheit der ukraine
innen sondern eben auf europa die
demokratie und unsere werte er hat
bereits vielen menschen das leben
gekostet
ganze städte zerstört tausende menschen
traumatisiert und gezwungen ihr zuhause
zu verlassen
und es ist verständlich dass es auch in
deutschland ein großes bedürfnis gibt
jetzt über sicherheit zu reden eben
nicht nur global sondern auch die
sicherheit der menschen hier und über
ihre eigene und wir sehen dass unsere
europäische aber eben auch die
internationale sicherheits ordnung
gerade systematisch angegriffen wird und
die frage ist die wir uns stellen müssen
wie gehen wir damit um wenn es eben kein
verlass mehr darauf gibt dass die
grundlegendsten regeln
grundlagen wie die charta der vereinten
nationen eben auch nur ansatzweise
eingehalten werden
und der jetzige krieg in der ukraine
verdeutlicht was uns auch schon zum
beispiel afghanistan schmerzlich gezeigt
hat sicherheitspolitik kann eben nicht
in silos gedacht werden sie besteht aus
vielen teilen aus friedenspolitik aus
diplomatie auch aus militärischer
verteidigung aus zivilschutz energie
cyber sicherheit und aber auch
entwicklungszusammenarbeit
und das ist natürlich nicht einfach
liebe kolleginnen es braucht absprachen
können sie mal einfach ihren mund halten
wird
es braucht absprachen und es braucht
vertrauen und wenn ihr sicherheit nicht
so komplex denken wie sie ist dann
wollen wir niemandem einen gefallen
nicht uns und nicht unseren partner
innen und hier können die reben
verantwortung übernehmen und mit gutem
beispiel vorangehen und dass unsere
außenministerin das erkannt hat und eben
jetzt in einer nationalen
sicherheitsstrategie zusammenfließen
lässt das ist ein großer erfolg und wir
brauchen eine leitende strategie für die
nächsten jahre eine strategie die
deutschland fest im netzwerk unserer
internationalen partner innen vor ort
hat verortet die sowohl sicherheits als
auch friedens strategie ist
ein ganz ein ganz kleiner moment der
kollege brender bei allem respekt die
geschäfte und möchte gerne intelligente
zwischenrufe aber ja dass ich sage ja
intelligente zwischenrufe eine rede wenn
eine rednerin nur stören zu wollen ist
einfach nur stillos bitte einloggen
eine sicherheits und frieden strategie
die eine analyse davon ist wer wir sind
und welche rolle wie in der welt spielen
und diese strategie ist auch eine chance
regelmäßig zu reflektieren gemeinsam zu
reflektieren gerade auch darüber was
sicherheit bedeutet und wer das wir ist
von dem in einer nationalen
sicherheitsstrategie gesprochen wird und
ich verstehe es zutiefst wenn er im
angesicht von militärischer gewalt sowie
sie die geraden die ukraine innen
erleben wie sie menschen weltweit
erleben bei sicherheit zuerst an
militärische aspekte denkt deswegen
diskutieren wir hier im hause eben auch
über waffenlieferungen über die aspekte
der bundeswehr und ihrer ausstattung
aber wenn man für sicherheit immer nur
einen hammer hat dann sieht man eben
auch überall nur eine nadel
lassen sie uns also wegkommen von dem
reinen militärischen denken von
sicherheit von sicherheit nur als waffen
von sicherheit nur als abwehr von
angriffen denn sicherheit kann nicht
ohne frieden ohne demokratie ohne
freiheit gedacht werden denn was
sicherheit am ende heißt ist frei von
sorge zu sein frei von sorge gewalt am
krieg zu erfahren aber auch frei von
sorge dass die lebensgrundlagen wegen
fluten oder dürren bedroht wird frei von
sorge dass man für sein aussehen seine
meinung sein geschlecht oder seine
sexualität verfolgt wird sicherheit
bedeutet in frieden zu leben und deshalb
braucht es neben militärischer
sicherheit auch zivilisten
reaktion den tausch gegen die klimakrise
abrüstung energiesicherheit und auch die
müssen hier eine rolle spielen und sonst
sitzen wir nämlich in einem jahr oder in
zwei jahren wieder hier in einer neuen
krise und suchen neue antworten und die
außenministerin hat ja eben deutlich
gemacht dass auch sie sicherheit komplex
versteht nicht nur in der rede zu
sicherheitsstrategie im auswärtigen amt
in den reden zumal ii zur ukraine zu
feministische außenpolitik und darüber
bin ich sehr froh
wenn wir sicherheit definiert hat einen
enorm starken einfluss darauf wer
wahrgenommen wird und dessen stimme
gehört wird und deswegen bin ich froh
dass der rechte rand satzung nicht zu
sorgen hat und
ich möchte gerne darauf eingehen an wen
wir eben denken wenn es um uns um wir
geht denn ich möchte eben nicht dass wir
da nur an das staatliche konstrukt
denken dass wir nur nationalen
strukturen denken ich möchte dass wir in
die sicherheit von menschen denken und
an der sicherheit der menschen nicht nur
im wahlkreis in dresden und bautzen und
sondern eben auch an die sicherheit der
jungen frauen in afghanistan
die indigenen aktivistinnen in mexiko
die für den erhalt ihrer lebensgrundlage
kämpfen und lassen sie mich gerne
erklären warum denn wenn wir die
sicherheit von menschen in den
vordergrund ziehen beschäftigen wir uns
automatisch mit den ursachen von
gefahren dann sprechen wir automatisch
über prävention und wenn es uns gelingt
dass wir alle mit denken nur dann
schaffen wir auch nachhaltige sicherheit
und wir müssen uns auch hier ehrlich
machen und reflektieren wo wir mit
unserem verhalten zur unsicherheit von
anderen menschen beitragen
und dafür haben wir eben den richtigen
rahmen die richtigen instrumente um so
über sicherheit hier zu sprechen
besprechen in den letzten wochen hier im
hause ebenso wohl über energie
souveränität als auch über die
ausstattung der bundeswehr
wir haben im koalitionsvertrag
infotische außenpolitik vereinbart die
eben genau das schafft die stimmen von
frauen von marginalisierten gruppen die
stimmen vor ort zuhören und ihnen gehört
zu verschaffen sicherheit ist komplex
geformte drittel meiner bitte kommen sie
zum schluss sicherheit ist komplex und
unser verständnis unsere instrumente
können deshalb nicht eindimensional sein
ich will dass wir all das in die
strategie im frau kollegin
bedauerlicherweise musste ich ihn jetzt
das wort entziehen mit 40 sekunden über
der redezeit nach zweimal der bitte
bitte sie jetzt das haus zu verlassen
nächster redner ist der kollege andrej
hunko fraktion die linke
und andrej hunko ist europapolitischer
sprecher seiner fraktion
vielen dank herr präsident meine damen
und herren wir reden hier über einen
antrag der afd nicht nur über eine
nationale sicherheitsstrategie sondern
auch für strukturen zur etablierung
eines nationalen sicherheitsrates und
dieser antrag ist wie vieles von der af
de zielt darauf ab
dass die strukturen in der außen und
sicherheitspolitik
zentralistische
undemokratische
nationalistische und militaristischer
werden und das reden wir als linke hier
ab
zentralistischer deshalb
weil sie wollen einen nationalen
sicherheitsberater bei mit mit stab und
so weiter beim bundeskanzleramt
ansiedeln damit wird die struktur
natürlich ähnliches frankreich ist ja
ihr vorbild zentralistischer
undemokratischer deshalb weil die von
ihnen geforderte parlamentarische
kontrolle aller wahrscheinlichkeit nach
völlig unzureichend sein wird
nationalistischer das ist hier schon
angesprochen worden weil sie ein
deutsches interesse als gegensatz zum
multilateralismus setzen wobei ich
natürlich auch die art und weise des
multilateralismus der bundesregierung
auch kritisiere weil die welt größer ist
als nur die nato und ihre verbindung
aber sie wollen ein
nationalistisches konzept und
militaristischer waren auch sie für
aufrüstung stehen all das lehnen wir als
linke sehr deutlich ab
wenn man sich mal ein wichtiges außen
und sicherheitspolitische entscheidungen
der letzten wochen genauer anschauen
nämlich die entscheidung schwere waffen
an die ukraine zu liefern
da muss man feststellen dass ja die
entscheidung faktisch getroffen wurde
auf einer konferenz in ramstein drei
tage nachdem noch olaf scholz sich sehr
kritisch dazu geäußert hat und wenn dann
die spd vorsitzende nachher sagt scholz
hätte ja im spiegel interview nicht
wissen können was drei tage später in
ramstein bekannt gegeben wurde
wörtliches zitat
dann ist das natürlich ein problem ein
demokratiepolitisches problem aber das
wird man nicht durch diese
zentralisierung strukturen der afd lösen
können frau später in berg sie haben
eben auf abrüstung für abrüstung
gesprochen ich spreche zu jeden frau
stellen berg reagiere
entschuldigung ich reagiere auf die rede
ich reagiere auch die rede die eben hier
gelaufen ist sie sprechen von abrüstung
und ich möchte daran erinnern dass die
bundesregierung ein massives auf
rüstungsprogramm beschlossen hat und das
leben wir auch als linker ab in dem
antrag der afd finden man die begriffe
diplomatie verhandlungen oder auch
vielen vergeblich die sucht man dort
vergeblich ich denke wir sollten viel
mehr in diese richtung diskutieren zb
darüber wie die osze mit es in eine
rolle bekommen kann in diesen aktuellen
furchtbaren krieg russlands gegen die
ukraine das wäre zielrichtung aber ich
glaube dieser antrag ist nicht
zielführend vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit
andrej hunko war das hat hier in seiner
rede auch noch mal seine vorrednerin
interne sperre werk angesprochen und wir
haben hier auch noch mal gesehen dass so
einer debatte eben auch nicht nur im
plenum stattfindet auch roderich
kiesewetter ist ja noch mal zu der
kollegin hingegangen und hat sich hier
nach den beiden reden mit ihr
unterhalten
jetzt geht aber weiter am pult peter
heidt für die fdp
die uns vorliegende antrag der afg
hinderlich schwach widerspricht ich
rückwärts gewandt und mit den gewohnten
nationalistischen unterton nicht ein
einziges mal habe ich in dem antrag eu
für alle nationen oder nato gelesen
vorne kritisieren sie ist übergreifend
und hinten fordern sie ressort
übergreifenden ansatz wahrscheinlich hat
die erste seite der müller geschrieben
die seite startete mayer keine ahnung
aber das ist doch grotesk
als antwort auf die wachsenden
herausforderungen einer veränderten
weltordnung fordern sie ausgerechnet sie
eine ideologiefreie strategie die allein
deutsche interessen formuliert ja dies
ist doch die sich ideologisch und
programmatisch in den europäischen
rechtspopulismus einreihte sie haben
noch immer nicht begriffen dass wir in
einer vernetzten welt leben und die
global sich als voraus
sicherheitsminister herausforderung nur
gemeinsam lösen können
russlands folge recht wenige anträge
auch die ukraine bedeutet eine
politische zäsur mit tiefgreifenden
auswirkungen auf die europäische
sicherheit es ist naiv zu glauben dass
wir uns nur aushalten können und alles
wird gut der fdp-abgeordnete gaul hat
erklärt den bundestag nur ein kompromiss
für den krieg beenden zu welchem preis
für tiere hat er nicht gesagt ein
commerce ist unmöglich wenn die eine
seite sich die vernichtung der anderen
seite zum ziel gesetzt hat er hätte an
kompromiss zwischen polen deutschland
aussehen können nachdem die nazis in
polen eingefallen sind die vorstellung
man müsse sich einfach nur ergeben alles
wird gut ist ein wunschdenken das
gegenteil ist der fall außerdem würde
die russische gewalt die in die menschen
in ukraine nicht aufhören wenn sie sich
ergäben würden butscher ist dafür
exemplarisch dass er weiß nur eine
elitäre starke position mit der ukraine
in eine verhandlungsposition bringen der
kein festes nachgeben angesichts
russland und mündlich anwalt droht
abgesehen davon dass es nach meiner
auffassung eine moralische verpflichtung
ist die ukraine zu unterstützen hat
putin bereits angekündigt dass er wusste
an in der alten größe die herstellen
will das ist jetzt die kfd als eine
friedenspartei inszeniert täuscht sich
darüber dass sie alles andere als eine
pazifistische partei ist natürlich geht
es gegen die usa für russland auch wenn
man auf die und linke zunächst einmal
als etwas unterschiedliches ansieht auf
diese position können sie sich immer
einigen sie verlieren sich beide in
jeder kruden russland liebe die
bestätigt sich wieder einmal die
hufeisen theorie von kabarett ihre
verurteilung des russischen angriffs ist
halbherzig und ihre ganzen anträge in
diesem parlament zeigen dass sie das
gegenteil sie sind tatsächlich die
fünfte kolonne russlands
könnte ich bunte präsentiert werden
teilweise russische propaganda zum
besten gegeben die landtagsabgeordnete
ja donau post in sozialen medien die uri
damit end zertifikat ihre haltung auch
die da drüben ist nämlich blanker
zynismus die ampel koalition nach den
letzten wochen gezeigt wie man auf einen
solchen angriff reagieren kann im
verbund mit partnern haben wir gemeinsam
hilfe beschlossen wir haben sanktionen
beschlossen wir liefern gemeinsam waffen
gewählten gemeinsam aus und leisten
humanitäre hilfe die tatsache dass
killer hat jetzt nato mitglied werden
will zeigt wie wichtig unser handel ist
und wie attraktiv die dato ist
voraussetzung für unsere sicherheit ist
dass hier alle staaten europäischen
union zusammen halten das wegen der
radtour ein starkes bündnis liegen die
bundesregierung hat wie schon im
koalitionsvertrag angekündigt und von
der fdp bereits 2020 gefordert eine
nationale sicherheitsstrategie in
angriff genommen es wird die erste
nationale sicherheitsstrategie der
bundeswehr deutschland sein wir
definieren interessen natürlich auch
deutsche interessen aber es geht um die
wehr fähigkeit deutschland das
anerkenntnis militärischer macht als
wichtiger ordnungsfaktor in der
international arena und entscheidende
stütze von diplomatie wir brauchen sie
als rüstzeug zur orientierung in der
welt wie sie nun einmal ist die brauchen
sie zur verständigung über reale
bedrohungen unserer wichtigsten
internationalen partnern in der eu und
in die nato ich habe an der
auftaktveranstaltung im außenministerium
angenommen die aussenministerin annalena
baerbock hat dort ganz klar eine
nationale sicherheitsstrategie skizziert
auf dieser basis arbeitet jetzt die
ampel koalition einen konkreten aus
regierung und kollege kiesewetter ich
bin gerne bereit ihre oderwiesen bereit
ihre anregungen aufzunehmen und bürgern
sehr offen über alle forderungen
diskutieren statt also wie sie es tun
sie den multilateralismus verunglimpfen
müssen wir im gegenteil daran arbeiten
ihn zu stärken und zu verbessern
deutschland ist ein nutznießer einer
regelbasierten liberal weltordnung
gerade deshalb muss deutschland
verantwortung übernehmen und eine
vorreiterrolle bei der einhaltung
internationaler verträge und
menschenrechte wir werden uns außen-
sicherheits- und tricks politik
partnerschaften vertiefen neue begründen
und unsere werte für freiheit demokratie
menschenrechte verteidigen liebe
kollegen kollegen nationalismus war das
große übel des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
wir wissen wo das hingeführt hat deshalb
wissen wir auch dass der nationalismus
heute keine antwort mehr sein kann
vielen dank
als nächstes erhält das wort für die
spd-fraktion der kollege johannes erhalt
und johannes als im
verteidigungsausschuss und war schon
offizier in der luftwaffe vor seiner
zeit hier als bundestagsabgeordneter
liebe kolleginnen kollegen ich möchte
der kollegin spellerberg bevor ich meine
rede einsteigen für ihre engagierte rede
denken was die fdp fraktion hier gemacht
hat sie gestört hat sie versucht hatten
ihrem rederecht zu hindern war
unterirdisch so wollen wir in diesem
wohnhaus miteinander diskutieren
nun aber zum antrag wir brauchen eine
umfassende strategie zum schutz unserer
bürger im ausland im inland und die
rolle von deutschland in der welt
beschreibt da sind wir uns alle einig
wirklich zählbares inhaltlich im
qualitativen sind enthält der antrag der
fdp fraktion dazu leider nicht denn sie
machen nicht was die fahrer seriösen
oppositionspartei eigentlich erwarten
dürften sie bieten keine lösungen an
sondern verbinden nur bekannte afd
generative das gut an ihrem antrag ist
dass ich die gelegenheit habe jetzt
darzustellen wie aspekte einer solchen
sicherheitsstrategie aussehen könnten
und mit einer verteidigungspolitischen
brille vielleicht auch einen ansätze für
eine lösung anbieten kann für einige
fragen
ausgangspunkt unserer überlegungen ist
die situation in europa die bedrohungen
demokratischer und liberaler werte eine
immer offener ausgetragenen systemen
konkurrenz zwischen demokratischen oder
autokratischen system die stellt erhöhte
anforderungen an unsere
entscheidungsqualität anders
entscheidungs tempo dazu kommen
herausforderungen wie klimawandel
migration und demografischer wandel wozu
brauchen wir also eine nationale
sicherheitsstrategie eine gute
sicherheitsstrategie ist ein kompass in
unsicheren zeiten und zwar nach innen
und nach außen er erklärt sie erklärt
bestimmt unseren standpunkt ohne panik
zu machen erklärt grundannahmen für
bürger und alliierten einfacher weise
den sinn ins eck von streitkräften
unseren blick auf die welt die kriterien
für eine sicherheitspolitische
engagement ausserhalb der landes und
bündnisgrenzen fest aber auch unsere
sicherheit nach innen wichtige fragen
können also sein welche bedeutung hat
die sicherheit und gesundheit unserer
bürger in krise und krieg und wie
stellen wir das sicher die haben wir es
erreichen also ein langfristiger
strategischer ansatz
was muss eine sicherheitsstrategie als
kompass leisten viele kollegen haben es
erwähnt wir müssen das ganzheitlich
denken wolfgang ischinger hat gesagt im
letzten jahr er würde die energie und
die gesundheitspolitik implodieren und
sonne durch eine strategie ich denke
aber auch die bemerkung von kollegen
kiesewetter dass wir finanzpolitik
soziale wirtschaftspolitik integrieren
müssen oder implodieren bisschen sind
richtig
dokumente wie die leitlinie zur
krisenprävention das weiß
die rahmenrichtlinie gesamt verteidigung
müssen im sinne einer ganzheitlichen
betrachtung dieser strategie
zusammengeführt werden es geht um nicht
weniger als ein fundament und die
vorstellung einer deutschen
sicherheitsarchitektur in europa alle
dimensionen von sicherheit müssen
zusammengedacht werden und zwar das über
die amtsperiode einer regierung hinaus
reine wahlperiode bei einem
größtmöglichen politischen konsens in
diesem haus
wir können also nationale ziele aussehen
einer solchen sicherheitsstrategien ich
denke es ja sehr wichtig dass wir den
mut haben diese ziele zu benennen uns
selbst zu erkennen profil und grenzen
unseres handelns zu definieren um
herausforderungen einem geeinten europa
zu bewältigen ziele könnten seien schutz
von leben sicherheit und gesundheit der
einwohner deutschlands
verteidigung der territorialen
integrität
souveränität und selbstbestimmung unter
allen umständen aber auch
versorgungssicherheit der schutz
gesellschaftskritischer funktion die
aufrechterhaltung unserer demokratischen
ordnung des rechtsstaates der grund- und
menschenrechte aber nicht zuletzt
stabilität und sicherheit in europa mit
unseren partner zu organisieren und zu
garantieren
die könnten verteidigungspolitische
elemente einer sicherheitsvorsorge in
einer nationalen sicherheitsstrategie
aussehen wir müssen mehr europa wagen
wir brauchen konkrete maßnahmen zum
ausbau einer engeren europäischen
zusammenarbeit unter rückstellung
nationaler egoismen im bereich der gsvp
wir brauchen vermehrte gemeinsame
rüstungsprojekte über den european
defence fand smarte beschaffung
gemeinsame bestellungen mit pulling
sowie mittelfristig eine gemeinsame
europäische rüstungs exportstrategie und
nur die kann zum ziel führen dass wir
die verteidigung europas im geist des
vertrags von lissabon organisieren
wir müssen mehr gesellschaftliche
verantwortung und verankerungen wagen
der bundeskanzler heute morgen
verteidigungsausschuss dargestellt wie
die ukrainischen bürgerinnen und bürger
ihr land verteidigen die das machen
natürlich mithilfe aber weil sie ein
verteidigungs wehen haben und diesen
verteidigungs willen müssen wir auch in
unserem land noch stärker verankern
wir brauchen ein integriertes system der
gesamt verteidigung über alle ebenen mit
klarer kompetenzverteilung der
katastrophenschutz und zivilverteidigung
über alle politikfelder von
bildungspolitik bis zu kommunikation und
schutzbauten bienen ein ikea bausatz
integriert die rolle der wirtschaft die
rolle gesellschaftlicher organisationen
unter zivilgesellschaft in diese
prozesse wir müssen auch darüber
nachdenken in welcher auch insa zions
form besser machen wollen wir müssen wir
innovationen wagen wir müssen wegkommen
von unbeweglichen der
institutionalisierten komplexe
systemlandschaften zu agieren und diesen
tauglichen strukturen die fähigkeit sich
schnell anzupassen und disruptive
technologie in unsere streitkräfte zu
integrieren militärische entwicklung
darf da auch technologietreiber sein es
bleibt festzustellen nach einem
nationalen sicherheitskonzept
benötigte konkrete antworten und
zumindest ideen gibt ihr antrag nicht
her die debatte um ein sicherheitsrat
als zentrales steuerelement wird teil
dieser sicherheitsstrategie so einzig
peter abschluss hätte ja eine
strukturdebatte kann über ziele und
mittel nicht ersetzen ich wünsche dir
für die debatte ist werden so
nachbarländer schauen ein verpacktes
dokument in klarer sprache formulieren
damit wirklich jeder und jede unseren
kompass unserem strategischen ansatz
versteht einen blick in die strategien
dänemarks und schwedens wäre da ein
guter hinweis vielen dank für
aufmerksamkeit
wir haben es alt war das und damit
kommen wir zum vorerst letzten redner in
dieser debatte zur nationalen
sicherheitspolitischen gesamtstrategie
das ist volker ullrich für die
cdu/csu-fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren es ist richtig über
eine nationale gesamtstrategie bereich
dass sich als politik zu sprechen
aber wenn wir über ihren antrag
diskutieren dann verläuft die trennlinie
in diesem hohen haus zwischen ihnen und
uns vor allem deswegen weil in ihrem
antrag
entlarvende sprachbilder
vorhanden sind ich will dass vor augen
führen sie sprechen zitiere vom krieg in
der ukraine ich glaube so sollten wir
nicht sprechen es ist ein angriffskrieg
auf die ukraine
sie sprechen von zitiere weiter
ideologiefrei strategie wenn man den
begriff der ideologie heranzieht dann
bedeutet ideologie ideen lehre oder welt
anschauen aber wenn es um
weltanschauungen gehen kann dieser staat
niemals neutral sein wir stehen auf der
seite von demokratie freiheit und
menschenrechten auch als ordnungsprinzip
internationale organisationen
und sie sprechen weiterhin ich zitiere
frei von der einflussnahme andere
staaten auch das ist ein sehr
irritierender begriff wir wissen dass
unsere eigene souveränität und das
wohlergehen unseres landes und der
bevölkerung davon abhängig sind dass wir
in internationalen organisationen
integriert sind und mit unseren nachbarn
gut zusammenarbeiten
wir können nicht frei von der
einflussnahme ist 1 und dem bund
gemeinsam unsere ideen voranbringen die
einbindung in die eu nato osze
es geht darum dass wir die
internationale ordnung stärken für das
völkerrecht eintreten für die frage wie
wir frieden und freiheit gemeinsam
sichern können das geht nicht in dem wir
uns abgrenzen in die zonen in dem wir
unsere stärken gemeinsam bündeln das
unterscheidet uns fundamental von ihnen
die herausforderungen vor denen wir
stehen können im großen und ganzen
beschrieben werden unter der überschrift
welche art von ordnung wird das
einundzwanzigste jahrhundert bestimmen
sind es staaten und staaten verbündete
die sich auf das völkerrecht auf frieden
freiheit demokratie und menschenrechte
stützen oder wollen sie dass die
autoritäre herrschaft letztlich die
oberhand gewinnt das ist übrigens auch
das um was es in der ukraine geht es
geht um die verteidigung von freiheit
und demokratie
die bilder des meiden und die
demokratiebewegung in der ukraine sind
der eigentliche feind russlands der hier
bekämpft wird und deswegen müssen wir
sagen dass in der ukraine auch
demokratie als ordnungsprinzip bekämpft
hat deswegen müssen wir auf der seite
der demokratischen staaten stehen und
die frage wie das in zukunft auch weiter
diskutiert wird es eine die uns sehr
stark beschäftigen muss wir haben die
einflusssphären von china beispielsweise
von russland die frage welches licht
stärker leuchten demokratie oder
autoritäre herrschaft wird uns in den
nächsten jahren beschäftigen und damit
muss sich auch eine sicherheitsstrategie
deutlich auseinander setzen wir brauchen
einen klaren schwerpunkt auf der frage
der zukünftigen
versorgungssicherheit klimafragen
eintritt für krisenprävention
demokratie und menschenrechte aber auch
soziale sicherheit als ordnungsprinzip
internationaler beziehungen und deswegen
ist es wichtig dass die bundesregierung
versucht ihre konzepte und strategien
stärke zu ordnen aber wichtig wird auch
sein das parlament bei dieser frage
nicht außen vor zu lassen durch unsere
ausschüsse
möglicherweise aber auch durch weitere
gremien durch intensive debatten weil
die fragen um die es hier geht betreffen
uns letztlich alle und geben die
richtung vor in welcher art von welt wir
leben wollen und ich glaube das kann nur
die welt von demokratie freiheit um den
berichten sein
vielen dank ich schließe die aussprache
winter so also dieser antrag der fdp
fraktion wird jetzt in die
entsprechenden ausschüsse überwiesen
über eine nationale sicherheitsstrategie
wird aber bestimmt häufiger diskutiert
eben auch weil aussenministerin annalena
baerbock eine solche angekündigt hat und
weil auch von der bundesregierung ja
schon gesagt wird man muss die deutsche
außenpolitik anders gestalten als das
bisher der fall war